in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Saul is
with us hi Saul how are you good Dave
how are you
better than I deserve where do you live
Lubbock Texas welcome to Nashville you
know one of our top guys here is a
Lubbock Texas guy you said it's so flat
there you can watch your dog run away
for three days that's about right I love
that line
welcome man good to have you thank you
so how much debt have you paid off a
little bit close to $48,000 way to go
and how long did this take you seven
months all right and your range of
income during that time went from making
about 60,000 a year to close to about
130 thousand a year you doubled your
income in seven months yes sir how
graduated nurse practitioner school that
helped in got every job that I could Wow
yeah yeah that you did you did do both
you got a great career and you maximized
it yes sir well done congratulations
so 48,000 the student loan debt student
loan debt from when I went to
undergraduate school initially
essentially that was debt that I
incurred when I went to school in the
early 2000s my parents initially took
out a lot of student loan in my name and
there was credit cards in there so by
the time I got to paying that off it was
quite some time later so that's where
that initial debt came from how did you
get through nurse-practitioner school
without debt join the United States Army
gave them a couple years of my life
there you go I'm overseas in Afghanistan
and they paid for my nursing my
bachelor's in nursing and my nurse
practitioner Wow that's wonderful
well thank you for your service and it
worked out for you huh yes there thank
you for the support very cool very well
done and so you're no longer in the
service I'm on reserve status I actually
had drilled this weekend and caught the
red-eye to come here to be here this
morning oh my goodness Wow well thank
you so much again congratulations so
what made you seven months ago decided
you're going to get this debt knocked
out this fast well like I said a little
bit earlier essentially my parents my
entire adult life had used my identity
to
take out student loans in my name when I
went to school the first time and credit
cards and store cards of all kind so
when I graduated school initially I had
a little bit over fifty five thousand
dollars worth of student loan debt
credit cards I had no idea it even
existed so when I went to join the army
after graduation initially I couldn't
even get a security clearance at the
time because I had so much debt builds
up but paid off you know enough to get
into the service and just been on the
journey ever since so you chose instead
of turning it in as identity theft to
pay it yeah my family you know
close-knit family no matter how much I
might have pressed my mom or my dad
about the student loan debt or the
credit cards or any of it and there was
you know we're family so you know in
spite of the numbers that didn't make
sense about how much school really did
pay for or a cost I just had to let it
ride for a long time and just let it
kept on going until I decided to do
something about credit cards you didn't
use at all no no I didn't then you paid
all those paid all those off came back
from a deployment from Afghanistan in
2010 came home when you leave as a
single soldier you have to leave your
life your life goes on even though we're
deployed so being a single soldier
knowing everything my parents had done I
was like you know they're not gonna do
anything while I'm deployed them I'm in
a combat area they're not gonna do
anything like that so what had happened
was I had my moment of being sick and
tired and being sick and tired when I
came home from that deployment you know
all my fingers and all my toes and I
never forget my dad sat me down and told
me son we borrowed some money from you
and looked at my bank account statement
and that was code for by the way while
you were deployed we were using your
checking account as our ATM machine and
didn't have anything to show for it so
at that point I really had that sick and
tired of being sick and tired moment
where I just looked at my life and said
I'm a college graduate I'm a combat
veteran I'm a sergeant United States
Army and I don't have anything to show
for it other than a mountain of debt and
piece of paper on the wall so none of it
that's your fault
so have you done something to stop them
from doing this anymore
at in 2010 I had talked to my parents
and I told them you know I
not drown with you anymore I told that
to my mother and my father and their
travel agent for guilt trip so that was
kind of hard to do initially packed up
all my stuff moved away change the phone
number and I decided that I wanted
better and stopped stopped it when I
decided to do something about it even
though I should have done it a lot
sooner yeah so they've not stolen your
identity since 2010 no I've got a danger
account and I've watched that thing like
a hawk number yeah I'm so sorry what a
heartbreak but you took responsibility
for every bit of it even though it
wasn't yours and cleaned it all up in
the last seven months Wow
congratulations so what is the key to
getting out of debt sergeant I would say
two things are the biggest thing one I
and this is first and foremost as the
mindset we talked about that in the
military a lot you can be a Viking or
you can be a victim and when when I
realized all this was happening you know
I cried I was upset and you know I could
either stay there in my pity and be sad
and cry but the debt wasn't going to go
anywhere I needed to take action to do
something about it
and I decided to be a Viking and go out
there with that warrior mentality and
get it done
and then having a big why to keep you
motivated as well I mean when you come
back from a deployment anybody that's
ever served in the military overseas you
take take a real big stock of your life
because there are men and women that do
not get to come home and I was in spite
of everything I might have come home to
I got to come home at least and I think
we honor those that don't get to come
home by living the best life that we
absolutely can so I suspect it makes you
appreciate the opportunities that a lot
of people take for granted yes sir I
mean that you can walk up and down the
street and buy anything you want to buy
you walk into a Walmart and there's more
stuff there than an entire country has
in other places and you can go I mean
and you've got the freedom to make
choices in your own life and economic
opportunity all around you and I suspect
you see that there are different lens
don't you it changes your perspective on
a lot of things when you kind of see
that so coming home yeah you take stock
of what's really important versus you
know things that aren't so much but yes
isn't it is very very cool well
congratulations there we're very proud
of you very very proud of you who was
your biggest cheerleader
I would save my girlfriend and her
parents Katie and Glenn they were really
big supporters my girlfriend was really
excited and we talked about it and why I
wanted to do it and you know before we
decided to you know get married even
though you say you don't have to be out
of debt to get married I was like this
is something I want to do on my own so
we can just have a clean slate and start
a whole new life and now you do yes
they're very well done well we've got a
copy of Chris Hogan's everyday
millionaires book for you we think
that's the next chapter in your story
sir you will be not only debt free but
now on your way to being a millionaire
nurse practitioner completely paid for
no debt at all making one hundred and
thirty and a bright future we're very
proud of you sir very well done thank
you thank you again for your service
Saul from Lubbock Texas forty-eight
thousand dollars paid off in seven
months making sixty to 130 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
[Applause]
I